c'est la liste donc de donner thuriau
qui gagne ce soir la mairie de nevers
avec votre soutient guillaume maillard
pour lui dit alors denis thuriau nous
expliquer que la ville de nevers ne
bascule est pas à droite mais élections
avec donc le soutien de l'ump de lui dit
votre analyse votre version votre vision
même si je vois que denis therriault
terre encore derrière vous donc pour a
confirmé ce que vous allez dire et vous
parler sous son contrôle j'allais dire
sous son contrôle bonsoir à tous je suis
pas sûr qu'on peut parler de contrôle on
a eu un beau combat politique inverse il
y avait cette liste au premier tour nous
avons mené notre propre projet nous
avons su nous entendre derrière un
projet commun le projet de nouvel avenir
c'est un c'est une victoire pour un
projet pour une pluralité pour
un projet de ville simplement peut-être
que nous devrions peut-être plus souvent
revenir vers ses fondamentaux
municipaux ville de varennes vauzelles
uni et d'en parler a également changé ce
soir autour d'une liste également
fédératrice sans étiquette c'est
peut-être là une nouvelle voie de
coalition je dirais ou de l'union autour
d'un projet qui qui qui arrive ce soir
en tout cas 43 ans de socialisme à
nevers je pense que tout le monde était
d'accord pour dire qu'il fallait engager
nos verts sur une nouvelle dynamique qui
est nous avons su prouver ou non vers
soi que nous avions ses ambitions je
suis un citoyen avant d'être un homme
politique je suis chef d'entreprise on a
des on a des compétences les uns et les
autres et on va les mettre en oeuvre
pour arriver à mener nos verts vers sète
cette nouvelle ère mais guillaume
maillard donc denis therriault nous
disait tout à l'heure que vous allez
c'est vous avez laissé vous de votre
étiquette un peu à la porte en vous
mettant sur sa liste est ce que ça veut
dire que vous laisser aussi des valeurs
de l'ue 10 à la porte en rentrant sur
cette liste et s'intéressera notamment
françois sauvadet qui sur ce plateau
bonsoir françois absolument pas je suis
je suis dans la famille udi j'en suis
fier j'ai mené les élections cantonales
en 2011 sur le canton de pierre
bérégovoy nous avions fait un très beau
score jean luc martinât en 2008 avait
mené le combat pour les municipales on
voit qu'au premier tour lui d y
progresse de 4 points par rapport au
score au score des législatives donc on
voit qu'il ya une nette progression de
notre famille politique au sein de
nevers après il était nécessaire de
mettre en en bémol nous étiquette
politique autour de ce projet de
rassemblement si nous voulions gagner à
nevers puisque l'ambition c'était
quelque part un référendum pour ou
contre le maire sortant et son système
je pense qu'on a tous été intelligent et
on a tous décidé ensemble de gagner
maintenant l'étiquette udi m'appartient
je suis allé dans mon coeur et on va
travailler pour les prochaines échéances
il d'ailleurs des cantonales des
régionales des législatives il ya un
mouvement qui se créent nous avons tout
notre autonomie par contre au sein du
conseil municipal je serai un élu nevers
à venir aux côtés de denis et j'en suis
très fier merci guillaume maillard en
direct de nevers dons